- [Presenter] This UCSD-TV
program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest programs.
(inspirational piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large brain,
long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
for the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans
like you.
(bright piano music)
- I have been a professor of medicine
and a clinical cardiologist
at UCLA for about 25 years,
but about 12 years ago,
I got a telephone call
that changed my life,
and that call came from
one of the veterinarians
at the Los Angeles Zoo,
and he called me because
one of their chimpanzees
had woken up with a facial droop.
They were concerned that
she might have had a stroke
and he asked if I'd come to the zoo
and image her heart to
look for blood clots
and other things that
might've been the problem,
and this was the hospital
at the zoo that I went to.
And this is actually me with
my first non-human animal,
and I'm gonna come back
to her in just a moment,
but a few weeks after I
visited with this chimpanzee,
I was asked to rule out a
torn aorta in a gorilla.
And not long after that,
there was a California condor
that they noted a heart murmur in
and they asked if I would look to see
whether one of the valves was torn,
which in fact it was.
There was a California
sea lion whose lower body
had filled with fluid
and they were concerned
about congestive heart
failure and asked if I'd come,
and in this picture, I'm
listening to the heart of a lion
who had had a collection
of over 700 cc's of fluid
in the sac in which
her heart is contained,
and in a collaborative procedure involving
veterinarians and human cardiologists,
we drained the fluid from her heart,
and this, by the way, is a
procedure that I have done
on hundreds of human
patients, but I must say that
the procedure itself was identical
to the procedure that I've done on humans,
with the exception of this
(audience laughs)
and, where is it, there we go, and that.
Let's get back to my first
patient, this chimpanzee
who had had the suspected stroke.
I remember when I first put the probe
into her mouth and slid
it down the esophagus,
I turned to the screen
and this is what I saw,
a four-chambered beating heart,
a left ventricle, a right
ventricle, two atria,
but I noticed that there were blood clots
moving these round, bouncing balls
and that the upper chambers were enlarged.
And as soon as I saw that picture,
it reminded me of a human
patient I had imaged
at UCLA some weeks before
who had the enlarged atria
and the blood clots, and I
realized that these two patients,
one human and one chimpanzee,
had spontaneously developed
the same kind of
infiltrative heart failure
that I had been treating for
years with high technology
and advanced pharmaceuticals,
and I found myself
being a little bit surprised.
But then I was more curious
about why I was surprised.
I mean I certainly knew that we shared
a common ancestor with chimpanzees between
five and seven million years ago,
which of course is a blink in the scope
of evolutionary time,
and as an undergraduate,
I had worked for four years in
a Museum of Comparative Zoology.
But when I had gone to medical school,
and like most medical students today,
what I had learned the connection between
animal and human health
was was infectious,
pathogenic, zoonotic.
And of course there is no question
that animals play an important role
in the transmission of diseases that have
a high impact on human communities,
even more so now, the One Health Community
is helping us realize that
the majority of infections
that will impact human populations
are coming from animal reservoirs,
but what I didn't learn, and
most medical students don't,
is that the father of modern
medicine, Sir William Osler,
is also considered the father
of modern veterinary medicine
and that one of his teachers,
the father of modern
pathology, Rudolf Virchow,
wrote in the 19th century, "Between animal
"and human medicine,
there is no dividing line,
"nor should there be.
"The object is different,
but the experience obtained
"constitutes the basis of all medicine."
But what I was finding
was that while I was
taking care of my human patients at UCLA,
I would go to the zoo and I would hear
the veterinarians discuss the management
of metastatic breast cancer,
or the management of brittle diabetes,
or the dosage of serotonin
reuptake inhibitor drugs
like Prozac for some of their
patients who were anxious
or compulsive, and I
realized that as much as
I knew about human
medicine, I knew so little
about veterinary
medicine, and it turns out
there has been a gulf
between these two fields.
Now there are many reasons for that,
some are historical, some are cultural,
but I'm gonna focus on two for a moment.
This first, I believe, has to do with
our essential ambivalence about embracing
our own animal natures, but the other
is human exceptionalism.
We all are scientists, many
of us are scientists here,
and we theoretically
accept that human beings
are merely one species in a
spectrum of other species,
not uniquely unique, but
unique like all others.
Love this.
We can zone in and see, here we are.
And yet, and yet, even the most
scientifically-minded of us
may harbor some residual
human exceptionalism.
In fact, I believe there
is a medical expression
of human exceptionalism
which is contributing
to this gulf between the fields,
and I became curious.
What is the extent of the
overlap in the pathology
of humans and animals, and so I asked,
do non-human animals develop?
Heart attacks or heart failure?
Type I, Type II diabetes?
Brain tumors, concussions, strokes,
asthma, allergies,
breast cancer, leukemia,
infertility, painful
periods, sexual dysfunction?
And of course the answer to every one
of those questions is yes.
Now, of course, our bad human habits
amplify the risk of disease.
It is the basis of preventative medicine
and I have spent 25 years
encouraging improved diets
and more activity, and yet,
although our bad human habits
may increase the risk of disease,
the essential vulnerability
to disease is ancient.
Let's quickly talk about two big killers:
breast cancer and heart disease.
We know that breast cancer
has a high human impact
on the human community.
It's the leading cancer among women,
but breast cancer is not unique to humans.
In fact, many of you who have cats
may know that cats are at risk,
dogs can be as well.
This is a mastectomy scar from a cat
whose owner felt a mass
when she was petting her,
and in fact, breast cancer has been found
in mammals of almost every variety,
from polar bears, to
elephants, to marsupials,
llamas, marine mammals, beluga whales.
In fact, notably, there seems to be
a particularly high rate of breast cancer
among some big cats.
We can talk about that another time,
why that might be, but it's notable,
one fascinating connection is that
the reason that some
jaguars have a particularly
elevated rate of breast
cancer is probably related
to a mutation of the BRCA1 gene,
and it is the same mutation
that makes some human females
at elevated risk for breast cancer.
Now of course there are
regions of the world
where practices, habits,
genetics, diet are different
and the rates of breast cancer are lower,
but that merely underscores the fact
that while our bad human
habits may increase
the risk of our disease,
the essential vulnerability
to disease is ancient.
The age of mammals started
about 200 million years ago,
and I suspect that the
vulnerability, therefore,
to breast cancer can
be stated, in a sense,
to be as old as that.
What about heart attacks?
So cardiovascular disease,
it is the number one cause
of death globally.
In the United States, those
statistics are amplified,
and we know that most
heart attacks are caused
by the progressive build
up of atherosclerosis
in the arteries that
eventually that atherosclerosis
breaks, there is a blood clot that ceases
the flow of blood through the artery,
and the muscle downstream dies.
And in this section of an artery,
you see the atherosclerosis, the plaque.
It has fractured, there is a blood clot,
and this individual died of a stroke.
But this individual was not a human.
What we see here is an Egyptian Vulture
flying in the base of the Himalayans,
and it turns out that if
you look at a phylogeny
of atherosclerosis across avian species,
every place that there is a star,
there's at least one
species within this order
in whom atherosclerosis, and stroke,
heart attack, and other clinical
syndromes have been seen.
Now, of course our bad
human habits amplify
the risk of disease.
I've spent my life as a
clinician helping patients
modify their lifestyles.
We know that.
We know that bad human
habits do contribute
to heart disease, but
recognizing that atherosclerosis,
and heart attacks, and
strokes have been identified
in animals as varied
as walruses, dolphins,
camels, and of course
humans, suggests that
while bad human habits may
amplify the risk of disease,
the essential vulnerability is ancient.
And again, the timeline
pointing to atherosclerosis.
And if this is true of
the somatic diseases
like heart attack and breast cancer,
it is also true for mental illnesses.
There is a hair-plucking
syndrome seen here
in this picture where
people pluck out the hair
of their eyelashes, of
any part of their body,
but it is remarkable that this bears
a similarity to a hair-plucking
and feather-plucking
syndrome that is seen
in some bird species.
You can see that this
parrot has plucked, denuded,
his thorax.
And it is notable that the
compulsive tail-chasing
seen in bull terriers,
treatable with Prozac,
or the flank-sucking, the
compulsive flank-sucking
seen in dobermans, treatable with Prozac,
bears similarities to
the compulsive behaviors
we see in some humans with
obsessive-compulsive disorder.
And it is notable, that
like some human beings
with anorexia nervosa,
some non-human animals
respond to social stress
by starving themselves,
sometimes to death, while
others deal with stress
by causing themselves to regurgitate.
Our bad human habits may
increase our risk of disease,
but the essential vulnerability
to disease is ancient.
Why is this important?
There are scientific and medical advances
that can come of thinking comparatively,
looking across species.
Translational medicine traditionally means
taking research that is
being done at the bench,
in the laboratory, and
bringing it to the bedside.
But I would suggest that
there is another way
of working translationally, and that is by
looking across species and
across time for connections
that generate novel
hypotheses that can ultimately
be translated into science
that can save lives.
Furthermore, I believe these
insights have the potential
to reduce stigma and increase compassion
for people suffering from physical illness
and mental illness.
I would like to end by modifying the words
of the late, great Susan Sontag
to reflect the species-spanning
nature of health
and disease, and the deep
and ancient connection
we all share, not just
with other human beings,
but with all of the
patients on the planet.
She wrote, "Illness is
the night side of life.
"More onerous citizenship,
everyone and everything
"who is born holds dual citizenship
"in the kingdom of the well
and in the kingdom of the sick,
"and although we all prefer
to use the good passport,
"sooner or later, each of us is obliged
"to identify ourselves as
citizens of that other place."
Thank you for your attention.
(bright piano music)